plenty of trade activity in advance of
the deadline it was jaylen ramsey a
couple of weeks ago we had three trades
last week two so far this week there was
a third one yesterday too the eagles
picked up gennard avery from the
cleveland browns he had a strong rookie
season but kind of lost the playing time
battle to guys like miles garrett and
olivier vernon so today is the day the
window closes
permanently or at least until march of
next year big cat and there's some names
out there that are floating around and
you know it's funny let's start with oj
howard the buccaneers tight end a first
rounder in the not too distant past they
have taken the position for weeks he's
not going to be traded he's not going to
be traded you know what now oh he's
available for a substantial offer of
course he is he always was these teams
say a guy isn't going to be traded just
to get maximum value for him
almost every player in the nfl is
tradable if you get an offer you can't
refuse and oj howard is no different and
the buccaneers at this point they don't
use him right for whatever reason he
hasn't clicked with the bruce arians
coaching staff so you get what you can
and you move on
yeah you put him in a new situation
he would be someone because he's still
young that you
would trade for being like hey if we get
him in a different system kind of a
change of scenery guy maybe we can make
something out of him because he was such
a high pick not too long ago who are the
teams mike who who are we looking at for
o.j howard who's who's kicking the tires
on o.j howard right now
well i don't know who's actively kicking
the tires but i mean we're gonna we're
going to put new england out there
anytime any tight end is potentially
available because they have nothing at
tight end right now and they picked up
muhammad sunu last week now i don't know
after giving up a second round pick for
sunu that they would want to go ahead
and make the move for o.j howard but
he's an alabama guy you got the whole
nick saban bill belichick thing
belichick gives nick a call they have a
little conversation what's o.j howard
all about and i could see the patriots
having an interest the question is will
they offer enough to get the buccaneers
to do it and here's the other thing too
when you go from we're not going to
trade the guy to well we'll trade him
for a substantial offer by the time 3 59
p.m eastern rolls around it could be
we're gonna take whatever the hell we
can get for this guy so it may just be
an auction even if it's a third round or
a fourth round pick that could get it
done but i would watch the patriots just
because you've got this constant sense
that hashtag tommy isn't thrilled with
the offense and he'd like more weapons
and they ran off a couple of weapons he
felt good about so maybe you give him a
tight end if it looks like gronkowski
isn't going to come back and that's
really died down in recent weeks i would
keep an eye on them for a possible
destination for o.j howard and the
seahawks and the seahawks because they
lost obviously a couple of weeks ago yes
what was that hashtag tommy what what
was that what did you just do tom brady
we call him hashtag tommy from time to
time yeah tom brady that
that that's actually you want to know
the whole story i'll tell you the whole
story when scott piolli was with us in
2013 on football night in america he
would refer to him as tommy so dan
patrick started calling him hashtag
tommy so i still i refer to him as
hashtag thomas okay
here's
i like that that makes sense and then
the trent williams stuff is the other
part where the have the redskins
sufficiently screwed this up enough for
your liking i mean this is or do they
still have time to screw it up a little
even more because it's time to screw it
up
until they trade him
i will believe they have a chance to
screw it up and i will not be shocked if
four o'clock eastern rolls around and
he's still a member of the franchise and
i also won't be surprised
if something happens remember that
bengals browns trade from a couple of
years ago they were trying to who are
they trying to trade for it like aj
mccarron remember that hugh jackman
tried to trade for aj mccarron and sasha
brown sabotaged it
at least that was the impression and
they sent in the paperwork incorrectly
to keep the trade from happening like i
could see something like that derailing
a trade for trent williams ultimately
caused by bruce allen and company in
washington to keep this deal from
happening once they finally get a deal
in place it's crazy to think that you
have a player who does not want to play
for your franchise who is a very good
player who can get you back draft picks
and you haven't figured out a way to
make that happen it's insane just
explaining the situation the redskins
are really bad they need draft capital
they have a player who actively has said
i will not play for you and oh yeah he's
really really good and everyone needs
offensive linemen no matter what team
you're talking about because it's a
really hard position to play so it's
just crazy this hasn't worked out i
would assume the browns are going to try
to do this and salvage their season the
browns and you've said this mike their
their schedule does get a lot softer and
there is a path out there for them to
get to nine wins and possibly sneak into
the playoffs that six seed and the afc
will probably be nine and seven so i
wouldn't be shocked the browns try to
get him and maybe sure up that offensive
line so baker mayfield has a chance to
throw the ball downfield
i think the logic for bruce allen
throughout this process has been we're
just going to refuse to engage in trade
talks on trent williams until the final
24 hours because he's not going to be
with us anyway the draft pick that we
get is still going to be the draft pick
let him hold out and lose all that money
and then in that last 24 hours we're
going to make our move and somebody's
going to give us what we want and i
don't think they're going to get what
they want the question is will they take
what they can get
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports